peu
[Musique]
m
vous avez le petit ruban c'est le signe
distinctif des célibataires oui et vous
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
kermesse mais j'attends d'eux j'ai
l'espoir de rencontrer
on a cherché je viens pour admirer le
site est peut-être tout faire pour
trouver une âme soeur oui vous savez que
vous avez la possibilité d anton
relations épistolaires avec des épées
des adresses dont je vais prendre à
demain ce que je regrette simplement que
on voit énormément de garçons avec des
assidus on voit pour beaucoup de femmes
quelles sont vos premières impressions à
12 heures je vais en bramant
quelques-unes adresse je vais est clé
pour arrêter ce qui si vous être le
bonheur risquer de me sourire voici une
fois cette candidate au mariage ont pas
du tout alors quel âge environ 18 ans
est ce que vous lisez les annonces
matrimoniales ne m'intéresse pas
beaucoup je vois rien mais comme le
copain
nous comptons oui des visions oui moi je
viens de la maison je suis de temps vous
êtes célibataire un oui c'est ma terre
candidates au mariage
non pas encore vous êtes célibataire
tous les deux vous venez d'où monsieur
toulouse toulouse aussi qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez comme jeune homme sportif
moi je vois une femme et m 80 et
d'arrivée ne s'incarne parce que c'est
ce qui me font moins peuplées comme lui
le médecin
soixante dix 83 ou se trouvant ça pour
vous je fais 80 moore on a vu en vrai
vous savez moi j'ai pas tellement
écrivain quel est votre type donne même
elles définiront ne suffit pas vous
l'avez rencontré ici non non mais rien
aperçu qu'ils pourraient s'en approcher
on reviendra l'année prochaine
j'espère bien a fait mais je trouvais
quand même j'avais trouvé j'attends
l'ouverture du bal là pour me remettre
et commencer les travaux approche
oui oui ça y est c'est plus sa réponse
est sans répondu c'est la plus grande
arène
tous ceux qui s'occupent d'elle
maintenant je sais c'est si bon d'aimer
comme ça on sert tous les soirs on
espérait que ce voile et moi je
on serré
m
[Musique]
et moi je me dis
merci mais 0612 sais pas si tu les veux
voir ou pas mais je vais d'ailleurs que
si vous voulez pas vous ne dites rien
numéro 7
un peu trois parties bon ben on avait un
très bel accueil à 8 1 2
et bien voilà je pars ans à sa reine des
célibataires c'est odile odile comment
peng quel âge avez-vous 23 ans
et qu'est ce que vous faites dans les
ptt dites moi on dirait ce que vous
croyez que lorsque vous marierai
le fait d'avoir été élue reine des
célibataires sera un atout de plus pour
vous faire apprécier de votre mari on ne
sait pas ça dépendra je sais pas comment
il le prendra
vous allez rester célibataire longtemps
depuis longtemps possible sa lumière
[Musique]